the 2014 consumer satisfaction index
came out where they ranked how people
feel about certain companies and the
value of their services and believe it
or not you know what two companies
people hate the most yeah Time Warner
and Comcast and of course Time Warner
and Comcast are actually merging to
become one more evil corporation so I
thought to start here I know that you
hate time warner you've gone on Twitter
rants about time warner so let's just
start with time warner yeah this is when
i wish corporations were in fact people
so i could kill them so they're not
people yeah i would like to murder time
warner okay I would it is such a bad
company in terms of service their lack
of respect for the customers and the way
they treat people I mean in fact it to
stay at your house all day you did like
take a day off from work yeah literally
all day I am to 5pm yeah we're and then
doing a [ __ ] show up and and I was so
angry and he burns say well why do you
Time Warner's you should detach from
from it's not for my television so I kit
for my internet yeah I need internet
access and where I live in LA they are
literally the only choice I have there
is no other choice yeah even if I want
to pay fifty thousand dollars I can't
get another choice this is it yeah so
the fact that Campbell companies are not
treated as as a utility is insanity they
should be deemed a utility and we move
on because there's no way you can
compete against time warner I mean the
idea of a free mark is that you know if
Dave ribbon was about Indian restaurant
and and then Malcolm opens one up and I
open one up the one that hasn't love in
the infamous for their every right all
right but you know the one that does the
best is presumably the one that has the
best food for the best price well you
don't have that kind of competition
there is no such free market for a
massive utility like the water company
Electric Company and the cable company
and pretending the cable companies are
not a tility is this ridiculous right so
to your point now Time Warner is
actually merging with comcast that makes
it a lot worse well I think it's sort of
like when you have a two people like a
couple and they fight all the time and
they're both of noxious and you know
they never get along and it's awful and
they're like you know what all that
we're gonna going to solve all this bike
married we'll get married and as we got
with the with Comcast and Time Warner's
that the questions are will they be as
awful as time warner or as awful as
comcast but it's not there even were you
happy but your way point is about the
monopoly is what is their incentive to
provide good customer service oh and do
in the article you you know that your
producer forwarded to us as they mention
that Comcast they're making some steps
one of the things they're doing is they
hired someone to come in and teach them
how not to constantly [ __ ] over your
customers like I mean I'm just wondering
looking at that meeting of the guys got
me was doing a slide show for I was like
okay so when the customer calls you're
going to want to pick up that phone yeah
we don't just keep running that loop of
your your call is important to us please
stay holding on the line over and over
again you want someone on the other end
to actually actually and then when they
express what their problem is you you're
gonna want to try to solve that problem
yeah you know the executive steverson no
wait wait what uses Abbott saw was that
was that work wait can you just explain
to me why is it that every time you call
these guys you have to punch in your
phone number right you have to actually
like tap you know I some buttons to get
it in and then the second they get on
the phone with you they ask for your
phone number again why is that if I met
me steve-o there's no explanation I i
I'm amazed when I call some 800 number
or some customer service number and a
human says hello it's incredible I'm
like what are you a real person yeah oh
there's a human start sounding like
robots action yeah it's really amazing
so uh back to the mergers yeah this is a
real problem because there's already
like regional monopolies by these cable
companies but now they want to create a
national monopoly and they've hired 40
lobbying firms not 40 human beings are
40 different lobbying firms to push all
the Congress people and all the
influencers in Washington to approve
this deal if this is not a monopoly than
what is anyone did you say it's a
Steve's point I think is that their job
creators and then his murder is creating
a lot of work so if we allow this
merchants to go through we should just
take all of our laws against monopolies
and just just just throw them away which
was pretty much done already but so is
this one of the things we're Obama's
what kind of face
here because you know he said he was for
net neutrality but then he appointed a
guy that was the head to the head of the
FCC who work who was a lobbyist for the
telecom industry and then just a couple
ago I think it was the day after the
election he again double down and said
I'm for net neutrality but at the same
time he's appointing people that are not
so we have these companies coming
together and to me the bigger risks
still is net neutrality which the jury
is out on which could really screw us
yeah but that's not even a question
thank you for that encouraging note of
my optimism for the new year day yeah
got anything give me some hope I mean
Gators there's no hope for the online
people real there's no hope net
neutrality is gone it's gonna be gone I
me it's just a matter of time and I had
how they couch it it's gonna be gone all
right well I wish we could have ended
that one is slightly more inspirational
give me something here Malcolm something
slightly more well you know what you're
watching this now and they haven't taken
it down have they and we're recording it
on December 31st console right down